[موسيقى]
الإمارات العربية المتحدة ترسم صورة وبائية نادرة
تدفق عشرات الآلاف من الأشخاص إلى أكبر معرض فني
في الشرق الأوسط ،
وكانت دبي أول
إعلان تم إلغاؤه عندما بدأ الوباء ،
وكان أول إعلان رئيسي يتم
افتتاحه
في  في هذه الأوقات الصعبة التي
تستضيف 50 معرضًا من 31
دولة ، يعد المعرض نافذة على
تنوع الحياة داخل دبي
قبل الوباء ، حيث
اجتذب الحدث السنوي الذي يستغرق أسبوعًا
30000 زائر من جميع أنحاء العالم مع
العديد من المشترين المتميزين الذين نفقوا في
هذا العام.  يسيطر عليها
تطبيق آمن خفي
ولكن ساعات العمل الممتدة والضجة الهائلة التي
سمحت بخجل
من الأرقام السابقة للوباء ،
إنه نجاح هائل لمدينة
تعتمد بشدة على السياحة
لدعم اقتصادها ، فهذه ليست
دبي التي تصورناها
قبل عام ولكننا هنا
ولا يمكننا أن نكون أكثر سعادة لأن نكون منفتحين في
الإمارات العربية المتحدة ،
كان طرح اللقاح الطموح دافعًا رئيسيًا
للسلامة
والنجاح  إذا كان عدد سكان هذا الحدث
أقل بقليل من 10 ملايين
شخص ،
فقد تم بالفعل تسليم أكثر من 8 ملايين جرعة
مواقع للسلامة الوبائية في الحدث
وشكل فني داخله
أقنعة مطابقة وعلامات تباعد اجتماعية ملتوية
معروضة في كل مكان تنظر فيه إلى
المنظمين الذين اختاروا خيامًا جيدة التهوية
بدلاً من مراكز المعارض مع الموظفين
الذين يخضعون لاختبارات
كل بضعة أيام ، هذه الآن
إعادة التشغيل المطلوبة بشدة لعالم الفن
على أمل شق طريق لأحداث فنية عالمية مستقبلية ،
يمكننا المضي قدمًا ويمكننا أن
نعيش
بشكل طبيعي قدر الإمكان إذا ظللنا مرنين
مبدعين و  مبتكرة في هذه الأثناء
بالنسبة للفنانين أنفسهم ، أعطى الوباء
العديد من الإحساس الجديد بالهدف
عندما حدث الوباء لأول مرة ، كنت
مستاءً للغاية من حقيقة
أن دوري في هذه الحياة أو في هذا العالم
لا يبدو ذا صلة ولكن في النهاية
بدا الأمر كذلك.
الشيء الذي
جمع الناس معًا
بطريقة ربما كانت مختلفة بعض الشيء
[الموسيقى]